[Música]
a
[Música] [Música] [Música
] [
Música] [Música] [Música] [Música] [Música] [
Música] [
Música]
vá [
[Aplausos]
[Música]
é
[Aplausos]
[Música  ]
[Música]
[Aplausos]
indo
[Música] [
Música] é [Música]
vai [
Música]
[Aplausos] [
tenho [
Música] [
Música]
[Aplausos]
[Música]
n
[Aplausos]
[Música  ]
[Música]
oh
[Música] [
Música]
você
[Música]
[Aplausos] [
Música]
me bateu como um t de
BRS, não importa fraco ou
forte, tome seu tempo e faça seus
truques Tudo que eu faço é cantar
[Música]
Al  sim, eu preciso de
você para uma luz mais brilhante e um terreno mais firme
Quando você acredita em
mim, o amor vai me libertar
[Música]
hum, está frio em um
dia de dezembro, estamos em nosso
caminho alegre, cavalgando apenas cantando uma música,
descobrindo através da
neve, os sinos estão tocando  flocos de neve
formigando Rudolph sabe para onde
ir neste dia frio de dezembro
Estou pilotando meu escravo
o trabalho a ser feito na minha corrida de Natal
é uma
tarefa difícil, nenhuma garota, um menino sem um brinquedo, então
crie raízes, meus
queridos oito
[Música]
PA
em diante
Des
responda
movendo-
se pela
neve [Música] [
Música] [Música
] [Música]
n [Música
] [
Música]
sim
[Música]
como se
fosse, não importa, fraco ou
forte, tome seu tempo e faça seus
truques  Tudo que eu faço é
cantar, sim, eu preciso de
você para uma luz brilhante e do meu
chão Quando você acredita em
mim, o amor vai me libertar
[Música]
costumava não ser
mais agora o mundo está seor,
viver a vida é
perigoso, mas  há um m
para sempre, sim, você pode ser um
pássaro, conte as histórias que você ouviu
[Música]
e viva sua vida
hoje, não importa o que digam
[Música]
a [
Música]
ele [
[Música]
n